[Musique]
bonsoir c'est lors d'auditions publiques
sur lcp public sénat avec le figaro
notre rendez vous en direct du lundi
soir avec une question parmi toutes
celles qui vont être posées au cours de
cette heure que nous allons passer
ensemble va-t-il y avoir un avant et un
après confinement du point de vue
politique les français voudront
peut-être avoir leur mot à dire les
parlementaires également notre invité
aujourd'hui est justement marc fesneau
bonjour bonjour vous êtes ministre des
relations avec le parlement
comme tous les lundis nous allons
retrouver tout à l'heure tu as mme tran
huy est logique bouchée des chaînes
parlementaires et puis deux
parlementaires qui vont entrer en
dialogue avec vous qui sont avec nous en
duplex vincent eblé pour le sénat et
philippe gosselin pour l'assemblée
nationale ils se demandent eux aussi
quand la vie va reprendre normalement au
parlement parce qu'ils trouvent que
parfois ça va être trop vite et puis bon
mais ils vous diront tout ça et puis le
regarde il thréard du figaro à la fin de
cette émission n'oubliez pas que vous
pouvez réagir avec le hashtag auditions
publiques sur les réseaux sociaux ou sur
lefigaro.fr
le tout sera relayée par la relève des
rédactions du figaro l'âge que nous
retrouverons tout à l'heure une petite
question marc fesneau on est à la
deuxième semaine de confinement c'était
la rentrée des collèges aujourd'hui il
ya eu la rentrée des écoles la semaine
dernière puis certains notamment des
politiques disent moi si j'avais des
enfants nés sans vie va pas à l'école
qu'est ce que vous avez fait vous si
vous j'ai envoyé mon petit dernier qui a
6 ans à l'école sans crainte et ceux qui
sont en un peu plus âgés ils iront au
collège sans doute au début du mois de
juin sans crainte devaient pas craindre
en aucune crainte
d'abord il ya question d'exemplarité
parce que je peux pas la fois dire que
je trouve logique de reprendre le chemin
de l'école et ne pas se l'appliquer à
soi-même que sur une cohérence politique
mais au delà de la cohérence politique à
titre individuel est plus personnel
j'avais pas de crainte particulière et
j'avais côté enfant plutôt l'envi pour
eux de retrouver non seulement leurs
camarades mais aussi de retrouver une
vie une vie d'école ça très bien je
comprends les craintes ont pu se nouer
pour comprendre ces craintes là mais je
pense que c'est une bonne chose que les
enfants au fur et à mesure reprennent le
chemin de l'école
on l'a vu aussi des foyers épidémiques
se déclarer là ces derniers jours dans
des abattoirs c'est un secteur qui ne
s'est jamais arrêté de travailler il
mériterait une médaille aussi puisqu'on
parle beaucoup de médailles pour le ce
qui
travail je sais pas si ça relève de la
question d'une médaille on en parlera
peut-être avec monsieur gosselin puisque
c'est une partie une initiative qui
l'avait portée mais bon il mériterait
une médaille que nous attendions
méritent la reconnaissance comme les
comme tous ceux qui en première ligne e
les gens qui ont été dans les tenues des
caisses les gens qui ont été des
livreurs et des transporteurs tous ceux
qui au fond pendant la période de
confinement strict on continue à faire
vivre le pays mais la maison y vous
n'êtes pas trop trop prudent mais
pourquoi pas la médaille mais je vois
bien qu après quand on commence à dire
la médaille vous dites oui mais c'est
pas suffisant au fond et c'est vrai que
ce n'est pas dans ma tête au fond je me
dis c'est au delà de la médaille de la
reconnaissance de la nation à travers
une médaille qui est une bonne chose que
la part du symbole est importante au
delà de ça il y aura sans doute d'autres
dispositifs qui seront apportées a été
fait d'ailleurs au travers de la
possibilité donnée un certain nombre
d'entreprises de donner des primes à ses
salariés qui ont qui ont pris beaucoup
de responsabilités dans cette période
pour résumer la médaille c'est pour tout
le monde ou personne
oui enfin il me semble il ya un certain
nombre de gens qui ont pris leurs
responsabilités et qu'ils ont été au
travail alors que parfois il avait aussi
une portée et les craintes sur la
question des abattoirs ya un problème
manifestement de deux conditions qui
crée plus facilement la circulation du
virus sur lequel il faudra qu'on
travaille on en parlait encore tout à
l'heure avec le mini durant c'est à dire
le travail à la chaîne
les conditions sanitaires dix conditions
de travail d'hygiène dans un abattoir
son très particulier avec une des
espaces de confinement qui sont plus
grands qui explique sans doute ces cas
de clusters dans des abattoirs
il faut aussi travailler pour essayer
qu'on ne on ne voit pas se multiplier
ces cas on va accueillir maintenant
brigitte boucher de lcp
soit brigitte aussant francis vasseur
marc fesneau
c'est la deuxième semaine de
déconfinement qui a été entamée il ya 25
foyers de coville qui ont été détectés
70 cas dans des écoles pour autant est
ce que vous diriez que le déconfinement
et jusqu'ici réussi est ce qu'on va
pouvoir éviter la deuxième vague
deuxième vague en tout cas on fait tout
pour l'éviter comme dans la plupart des
pays européens qu'est ce qu'on constate
c'est que dans la plupart des périodes 1
le même chemin et est suivi en termes de
déconfinement jaurès à lui à la fois la
responsabilité des français dans cette
phase de déconfinement qui ont adopté
les gestes qu'ils étaient préconisées
les gestes barrière le port du masque
dans les ans cet espace où ça paraissait
obligatoire et puis tous ceux qui ont
veillé à bien organiser les choses qu'on
s'a ce aux personnels enseignants ou
personnels dans les collectivités
locales ou chefs d'entreprises aussi
qu'ils ont essayé de faire en sorte que
les conditions sanitaires soient les
plus conforme possible à ce qu'on
voulait pour éviter un pic épidémique
est donc c'est plutôt réussi jusqu'à
maintenant
pour l'instant moi je suis pas du genre
à moto congratulaient j'ai le sentiment
que d'abord les choses se sont faites
dans l'apaisement parce que
progressivement et c'était la volonté du
gouvernement
deuxièmement on en reparlera peut-être
tout à l'heure mais il ya une volonté de
faire les choses territoire par
territoire et de tenir compte des
spécificités territoriales de faire de
la différenciation territoriale en phase
réel si je peux dire donc ça s'est fait
dans le parler voie d'apaisement et
progressivement et je crois que tout le
monde dit tout est à saluer dans les
démarches qui ont été faites et
progressivement le pays sur mer marché
on le voit c'est quand même un test pour
le gouvernement politiquement j'entends
c'est un test pour le gouvernement mais
c'est un test pour tout le monde au fond
parce que je crois que tout le monde
aspire et au déconfinement et tout le
monde voyait l'écueil du déconfinement
de confinement avait été fait pour
éviter un sursaut épidémique trop
violent et pour éviter cette fameuse
courbe en u si je peux dire du pic
épidémique l'idée maintenant que la
courbe descendante c'est d'essayer de
tenir cette volonté-là de de maîtriser
l'épidémie
pour autant il ya jean castex qui est
monsieur déconfinement qui a préparé un
plan de re confinement au cas où est-ce
que vous pensez que les français
seraient prêts à l'accepter
et est ce que
et est ce que ce serait économiquement
intenable vous avez plusieurs questions
dont la première la deuxième est ce que
les français n'accepteraient vous croyez
oui probablement que sous la contrainte
si je peux dire d'un sursaut épidémique
probablement que ça pourrait être
compris encore qu'il faudrait l'étayer
expliquer ce que nous on est ce que ça
serait d'ailleurs l'ensemble du
territoire national où certaines zones
c'est comme ça que ça peut être aussi
posé cette affaire de confinement et que
est ce qu'il ya un risque économique oui
on sait bien que à cette crise
épidémique et à cette crise sanitaire
vient tout de suite derrière une crise
économique et donc une crise sociale et
donc il ya quand même besoin de tenir
cet équilibre et cette ligne de crête
entre les nécessités sanitaires et les
nécessités d'une reprise économique pour
le pauvre collectivement pouvoir s'en
sortir le plus rapidement censé venir
une crise sociale vous derrière une
crise économique s'il ya des plans de
licenciement si vous retrouver dans des
situations où des gens se retrouvent
demandeur d'emploi je pense que cela
relève d'une crise sociale
reconnaissons que nous sommes le pays
pour pas dire le pays qui a le plus
essayer de protéger les salariés dans la
période de confinement par les mesures
d'ampleur je rappelle qu'il ya près de
13 millions de salariés qui se sont
retrouvés dans un dispositif de chômage
partiel
c'est inédit en france c'est inédit en
europe regardez la situation américaine
où vous avez eu des millions de chômeurs
en plus mais d'autres situations il faut
quand même regarder est emparé de ces
américains on sait bien commencé oui
enfin pourquoi prégent et pourquoi ne
pas se comparer aussi aux américains de
temps en temps on peut aussi regarder ce
qui se passe de bien dans le pays et
considéré qu on a fait des choses qui
sont bien en même temps on a beau
c'était un moment dans la période de
confinement
la crainte qu'on peut avoir c'est que la
reprise économique tarde ans et des
difficultés venant je pense au secteur
de l'aéronautique par exemple il puisse
y avoir des des sujets économiques et
donc des sujets sociaux près des
tensions sociales et des tensions
sociales étant surviennent après mais je
veux dire la question sociale va être
encore au site ce moment retour au
parlement c'est qu'ici on a voté la
prorogation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire jusqu'au 10 juillet si
toutefois il n'y avait pas deuxième
vague et que la situation s'améliorait
ce qu'on pourrait imaginer qu'il soit
levé avant non il ya un horizon on est
quand même le 17 mai ou 18 mai il faut
peut-être se donner le temps de regarder
dans la durée un peu comment se passe le
pic épidémique est une temporalité qui a
été fixée au 10 juillet à la demande des
parlementaires puisque initialement on
était plutôt sur le 23 juillet
et donc c'est gravé dans le bar sinon ça
n'irait ce serait de revenir d'un point
de vue législatif sur la date du 10
juillet donc on va pas revenir pour un
horizon qui est assez bref c'est un mois
et demi ça permettra d'y revenir dans
ses horizons là alors on prépare un plan
pour l'hôpital c'est ce qu'a lancé hier
olivier ferrand il y aura des
augmentations de salaires les infirmiers
français gagnent en moyenne 6000 euros
de moins par an que les infirmiers
européens et leur pouvoir d'achat
baisser de 12% en 12 ans à 7 des
informations de l'insee
est-ce qu'on a les moyens de revenir
dans la moyenne européenne
d'après ce qu'on en a la volonté de ce
que j'entends de ce qui est dit le
ministre d'iran il ya la volonté quand
même deux pour procéder un rattrapage
c'est un certain nombre de professions
parce que ça participe de l'attractivité
du métier c'est pas le seul dispositif
comme je crois je pense que j'entends
aussi beaucoup de soignants qui qui
souhaiteraient qu'on réorganise
complètement la manière dont fonctionne
l'hôpital ou non la manière dont
fonctionnent les instituts qui s'occupe
de personnes âgées donc il ya la
question de comment on organise le
système de soins et j'ai entendu
beaucoup de malaise et de mal-être sur
ces questions là avant d'ailleurs la
crise du cours d'avis russie à la
question de la revalorisation salariale
tout sa procédera d'un certain nombre
d'annoncés qui seront faits qui seront
faites pas ce soir puisque le ministère
en a annoncé incertain processus de
dialogue
emmanuel macron a dit quoi qu'il en
coûte oui donc ça veut dire qu'on veut
augmenter pour revenir de cette moyenne
on est la sixième puissance du monde et
c'est très bien ainsi il ya aussi des
sujets budgétaire donc il faudra qu'on
pose l'équation budgétaire mais je pense
que la volonté du président la
république et du gouvernement c'est de
faire en sorte que des signaux clairs
qu'ils s'envoyaient ce ne sera pas quoi
qu'il en coûte donc mais si ça a était
quoi qu'il en coûte dans la période de
crise mais il ya un moment où cela a été
un moment voyez bien qu'il ya des sujets
budgétaire parce que quand là c'était la
question
le quoi qu'il en coûte était dans le
fond il faut reprendre exactement ce
qu'a dit le président de la république
il a dit je vais essayer de préserver le
tissu économique et social quoi qu'il en
coûte
ça ce qu'il a dit après je le pose d
équation budgétaire c'est c'est pas du
tout pour éluder la question on a
fermement la volonté d'avancer sur les
sujets que vous évoquez en termes de
revalorisations
il n'y a pas que le sujet de la
revalorisation me semble-t-il sv ce
métier mais ça n'entre pas dans le quoi
qu'il en coûte puisque c'est à dire et
là mais ça n'empêchera pas que ce sujet
est ouvert et le ministère en la très
très clairement ouvert en disant que
cette question de la revalorisation
salariale et de vettel sur la table
olivier ferrand toujours à annoncer un
ségur de la santé pour le 25
soit exactement et l'on peut imaginer un
plan santé au parlement dans les deux
mois qui viennent
ça dépendra de la nature du des annonces
qui seront faites si c'est des annonces
budgétaires ça s'inscrit tout à fait
dans la logique budgétaire qui se
déroulera à l'automne donc le projet de
loi de finances et le projet de loi de
finances de la sécurité sociale en
particulier c'est plutôt dans ce cadre
là que ça sera est ce qu'il y aura des
mesures législatives
il appartiendra à olivier vivant et au
gouvernement de regarder au plancher
solide au volant vous regardez plutôt
vers septembre et gégé 200 oui j'ai le
sentiment qu'on est plutôt sur une
équation budgétaire qui posait quand on
est sur des sujets d'organisation n'est
peut-être sur des dispositifs
législatifs mais voyez bien que la
concertation démarre le 23 mai les
horizons se hausser entre le mois de
juillet et le mois de septembre donc
c'est pas forcément dans l'été en tant
que c'est plutôt septembre pour pour la
discussion en bulles mais on verra mais
moi je suis aussi gardien des calendrier
parlementaire j'imagine que j'aurai une
question tout à l'heure on peut pas se
faire au même moment donc on met ces 2
septembre olivier ferrand toujours qu'il
veut revoir les 35 heures à l'hôpital
est ce que c'est un retour du sarkozysme
du travailler plus pour gagner j'ai
attentivement lu ses propos il a pas dit
qu'il fallait revenir sur les 35 heures
reconnaissons quand même apporter de la
souplesse dans l'organisation du travail
pas besoin de petit sarkozystes ou pas
sarkozy pas la peine de faire référence
à ces choses-là reconnaissons que faut
quand même se souvenir de l' affaire des
35 heures dans les entreprises privées
on a dit c'est pour recruter et dans le
temps les chez les fonctionnaires on a
10 35 heures sans recrutement
bah qu'est ce qui s'est passé on a mis
en tension en particulier un secteur qui
était déjà en tension qui est de 70 ans
mais c'est à cause des 35 heures
ou du manque d'embauché mais il n'était
pas prévu y compris par madame aubry en
97 de faire des embauches accord mais
c'est parce qu'il ya pas eu d'embauchés
sans doute qu'il aurait fallu embaucher
oui mais sans doute peut-être on pouvait
regarder les choses différemment et pas
se poser la question seulement de dire
on réduit le temps de travail sans faire
d'embauché on pouvait peut-être essayer
de regarder de la soupe la c'est donc ce
à quoi fait appel ou l'ignorance et de
regarder des assouplissements sur la
base de scorer serait la volonté des uns
et des autres de regarder quelles
seraient alors je signale qu'il ya un
certain nombre d'heures qu'ils sont dus
tous ces personnels qui ne sont toujours
pas soldé parce qu'ils n'ont pas pu
prendre leur comment dirais-je la
responsablité fait qu'ils ont beaucoup
travailler sans compter les heures et en
particulier dans la période combien le
marché nous ça bouge beaucoup à la
sensationnelle parce que dans quelques
heures on va apprendre la naissance d'un
neuvième groupe alors un neuvième
groupes parlementaires pour demain matin
a effectivement est ce que c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour la démocratie
je pense que c'est une bonne nouvelle
pour la démocratie on pourrait dire en
première intention cui c'est la première
fois qu'à l'assemblée nationale il y
aura neuf groupes parlementaires
un record qui est un record est-ce que
ça facilite le travail parlementaire pas
forcément mais bon après on en prend
acte justement démocratie qui fonctionne
après c c'est la décision d'un certain
nombre de députés qui étaient soit issu
du groupe en marche qu'il avait quittée
soit qui sont encore aujourd'hui dans
groupe en marche
je comprends mal pour tout vous dire la
temporalité au moment où je pense qu'on
aurait plutôt besoin de se rassembler
débattre et je dis bien de se rassembler
de battre je pense qu'on a besoin à la
fois de collectivement mais pas
seulement dans le groupe de la majorité
et c'est trouver les moments de
consensus pas pour chercher le consensus
simplement on voit bien que sur les
activités de relance économique on a
besoin on va avoir besoin collectivement
porter quelque chose
une petite une petite parenthèse parce
que vous dites ça risque de compliquer
l'organisation par exemple les questions
au gouvernement
chaque groupe a un temps de parole de
questions et c'est ça dure déjà deux
heures ça va durer trois heures
non c'est mécaniquement prix sur le
groupe kel plus de questions donc sur le
groupe de la république en marche et ils
vont pas être contents a tellement c'est
la mécanique c'est le règlement de
l'assemblée nationale pour lequel je ne
suis rien si je peux donner mais c'est
comme ça que ça marche comme ça que ça
passe une dernière chose que pour
répondre à votre question je comprends
mal la temporalité et je comprends mal
le fondement dès lors comme moi il me
semble que dès lors que nous arriverions
à mieux travailler encore dans le débat
et après tout qu on ait des choses en
débat à l'intérieur de la majorité je
trouve ça sain je comprends mal
l'utilité au fond brigitte une dernière
question rappelait alors une dernière
question emmanuel macron réfléchi un
acte politique pour se relancer après
cette crise et cette épidémie est ce qui
pourrait y avoir un congrès à versailles
début juillet factuellement il peut
toujours y avoir un congrès à versailles
début juillet il peut y avoir un combat
aussi début septembre il peut y avoir un
congrès à tout moment puisque c'est une
descente accord d'abord il convolait des
questions
est-ce que c'est dans l'air est-ce que
c'est dans l'air il ne m'appartient pas
de préjugés ou de présenter une décision
qui relève éminemment d'une décision du
président sarko et maniema pont avait
dit que chaque année ils reviendraient
et bien devant nelson a organisé ça nous
sommes le 18 mai on verra ce qui pour
l'instant vision d'un résident à
travailler pas là dessus pour l'instant
n'y a pas d'hypothèse du congrès au mois
de juillet si c'est ça votre question
mais c'est ça la question
mais ça s'apprend profond vous le saviez
pas brillé mais savoir c'est s'il y
avait une hypothèse à ce stade pas
d'hypothèse très bien ça reste ouvert
puisque je répète c'est une preuve bien
sûr merci
brigitte on va faire des tours
maintenant par le figaro live où nous
attend vincent roux bonjour bonsoir
vincent vous regardez pour nous vous
allez y arriver sur ce qui se dit sur
les sites et réseaux sociaux du figaro
live quel est le thème qui a retenu
votre attention à la une des infos les
plus lus aujourd'hui une des infos les
plus commentés celle annonce faite par
jean michel blanquer le ministre de
l'éducation nationale ce matin de 70 cas
de co vide détecté dans l'est dans les
écoles alors les internautes réagissent
de façon opposée pour les autres c'est
bien la preuve qu'il ne fallait pas à
réouvrir ses écoles
pour d'autres c'est exactement l'inversé
je les cite
avec si peu de cas c'était bien la
preuve qu'il fallait les ouvrir plus tôt
plus vite
cette polémique est inévitable juge
d'ailleurs un autre internaute
et j'ai retenu son commentaire puisqu'il
dit fallait bien s'attendre au fait que
je le cite sans les tests on ne pouvait
qu'aller dans le mur et de conclure les
tests sanguins devrait être obligatoire
pour les collégiens les profs ainsi que
les écoliers et les instits
qu'est ce que vous en pensez marc
fesneau est-ce qu'on pourrait pas
étendre justement ces tests à tous ceux
qui veulent qu'ils doivent aller
travailler votre réponse
il ya deux choses il ya les tests pcr
ceux qui sont dans la voie nasale si je
peux dire et les dresseurs sont guère
les tests sanguins il ya une question
d'abord d'aujourd'hui de d'efficacité et
de il ya un certain nombre de tests
sanguins pour pas dire la plupart dont
on mesure assez mal l'efficacité donc
être testés négatifs et être au fond
positif la deuxième chose si je peux me
permettre cette remarque vous fait
tester le lundi vous croisez quelqu'un
qui à corona virus le mardi vous fait
tester quand après le mercredi vous
voyez bien que la question des tests
sanguins
elle pose une question ça n'aurait de
sens d'ailleurs aucun pays ne le fait la
question des tests sanguins ont peut
être un peu le feu c'est que ça n'aurait
de sens que si instantanément tous les
jours vous pouvez faire 67 millions de
tests sans doute que se séparer les
hommes ce n'est pas réaliste et ça
devient réalise au delà de la défiance
scientifique qu'il ya sur la question
des tests sanguins
en revanche la stratégie qui a été fait
de dire quand quelqu'un présente des
symptômes on le teste et après on essaie
de tracer l'ensemble des personnes qui
ont été en contact avec lui ça permet
d'isoler les gens qui pourraient avoir
été en contact avec le coronavirus ça
c'est une
c'est une comment dirais-je ça me paraît
utile mais tester les gens une fois pour
après pu les tester
bon alors vincent voilà votre votre
internautes lecteurs à sa réponse merci
vincent d'avoir relayé cette
préoccupation est maintenant on va
accueillir thème traduit le public sénat
[Musique]
bon certes à mme bonsant francis bon
sens marc fesneau soir on va parler des
municipales puisque le conseil
scientifique rend aujourd'hui son avis
au premier ministre sur la date à
laquelle peut se tenir ce second tour
des municipales avec bien sûr cette
question peut-il se tenir le 28 juin
s'est salement premier ministre n'est
pas rendu public
ce sera rendu public le 1er unis s'y est
engagé il aura les éléments du rapport
ce soir ou demain matin ça sera rendu
public comme on l'a fait à chaque fois
qu'ils avaient un rapport du conseil
scientifique c'est ce genre de public
c'est à dire demain par exemple il
demain par exemple je trouve que c'est
bien que ce que dit le conseiller
scientifique soit mis sur la place
publique ça permet aussi donc demain on
en saura un peu plus
absolument est ce qu'il y aura un débat
suivi d'un vote au parlement sur la date
du deuxième tour alors le rapport va
produire quoi on verra il va produire à
la fois la capacité dans le cadre
épidémique dans lequel nous sommes
d'avoir deuxième tour à la fin du mois
de juin si c'est le cas ok mais est ce
qui donnera un certain nombre de
préconisations pour dire il faut le
faire dans telles conditions la campagne
doit se dérouler dentelle
évidemment ça pose des questions de
nature différente si cécile s'il ya un
feu rouge d'allumer si je peux dire sur
la question du vote après se posera la
question comment dirais-je d'avoir
d'avoir un vote qui soient décalés à un
autre horizon à l'automne au plus tard
bon ça c'est un premier élément deuxième
annonce qu'il faut un débat au parlement
oui la volonté du gouvernement c'est
qu'au moins là les partis politiques et
ceux qui animent le débat public puisse
se saisir de la question nous a fait
suffisamment leurs proches
j'ai une mémoire pas si ancienne qui
fait qu on nous a reproché avant le
premier tour de finalement de ne pas
avoir demandé l'avis des partis
politiques
encore que beaucoup s'étaient exprimés
comme on dit en automne ou en off pour
être là mais la tenue du premier tour au
fond que le débat public se nouent et
les responsables politiques prennent
aussi part aux débats et 10 et 10 puisse
dire ce qu'ils veulent d'ailleurs j'ai
entendu un certain nombre de
responsables politiques le président de
l'association des maires plutôt dire
qu'il souhaitait que ça soit fin juin
sinon fin septembre enfin plutôt fin
juin j'ai entendu christian jacob le
président party les républicains dire ça
j'ai vu la tribune un certain nombre de
maires de toutes obédiences politiques
réclamant la tenue du premier tour du
deuxième tour pardon à la fin du mois de
juin je pense que c'est bien que ce soit
dans le débat public on verra s'il ya
lieu de procéder à un débat et un vote
s'est pas encore tranché on verra s'il
ya eu lieu mais c'est pas sûr encore
sonné mais en tout cas que le parlement
un moment se saisisse de la question
n'éprouve là il se saisit par un vote
oui par avant tout par un débat
d'accord oui ça pourrait suffire puisque
gérard larcher le président du sénat
estime que les parlementaires n'auront
pas eu assez d'informations pour se
prononcer il est défavorable à ce vote
votre réaction je n'ai pas à commenter
la parole du président du sénat il a
raison en général je trouve que le fait
que nous ayons des débats sur des sujets
qui ont beaucoup alimenté le débat est
là conflictuelle it et politique qui
permettrait de dire voilà ce que les uns
et les autres posent pense en avoir un
sujet tout à l'heure sur la question
démocratique on peut pas à la fois nous
faire le reproche de ne pas donner au
parlement la capacité a démâté qu'on lui
propose de dire on ne veut pas mais
c'est une façon de dire mouillez-vous
quoi vais je
mais je pense qu'on n'est pas la
question la question n'est pas de savoir
s'il faut mouiller les uns ou les autres
je pense par opposition aux défis mais
c'est pas une question de mal face à
l'euro à ce jour ça voyez bien nous
sommes collectivement face à des
responsabilités compris les mères
d'ailleurs au moment de l'ouverture des
écoles qui sont des responsabilités très
lourdes et donc on partage au moins la
discussion et que chacun puisse émettre
un avis dans le champ politique ça me
paraît quand même pas une une folie en
démocratie que chacun puisse donner un
avis davos et lausanne savez même la
base de la démocratie pour tout vous
dire le deuxième tour ne peut pas
apprécier par des oui si demain matin le
premier ministe décidé j'ai décidé
unilatéralement de faire ci ou de faire
ça qu'est ce qu'on dirait qu'il y aurait
des critiques
le deuxième tour n'a pas lieu en juin
est-ce que ça va repousser les dates des
sénatoriales et pour vous quelles sont
les hypothèses quand est ce que les
sénatoriales pourrait avoir la main par
effet mécanique si les élections ne
peuvent pas se tenir en juin ne peuvent
pas se tenir en août sont pas que ce
soit raisonnable de faire des élections
plein coeur de l'été et donc ils se
tiennent en septembre et comme il ya les
élections sénatoriales dans cette tente
ça nécessite de décaler le camp
d'adriano en cale et on verra de 1 an
c'est l'équivalent enfin on verra ça
fera partie du débat parlementaire là
aussi pardon sur un sujet comme celui là
et c'est pas une intéressant d'avoir
l'avis du sénat certes il me semble pour
l'instant il s'est pas prononcé je veux
gêner personne pour la soul s'est pas
prononcé nathan de savoir une vue
générale sonne je pense que l'avis du
sénat et l'avis de l'assemblée nationale
sur tous ces sujets sur des avis qui
sont pas inintéressants des commission
denquête kiss him d'effectifs sur le
coronavirus on y revient le sénat a
d'ailleurs va donc lancer sa commission
denquête au mois de juin sur la gestion
du coc u19
est ce que vous craignez un procès
politique je ne crains rien d'abord
c'est un droit et donc je n'ai pas à
commenter ce qui est un droit et je
trouve bien que les assemblées puisse
saisir
la question vous lancer des cris c'est
le rôle d'un parlementaire mais c'est le
rôle d'un parlementaire j'ai été
parlementaire il m'a peut-être qui
m'arrivera leur devenir et donc je je je
trouve pas anormal que les parlement se
saisisse de la question c'est valable
dans toutes les grandes démocraties les
commission denquête sont faites pour ça
peut y avoir une interrogation sur la
temporalité est ce que bientôt il n'y a
pas lieu d'attendre qu'on soit sorti un
peu de cette crise parce que jusqu'à
nouvel ordre nous y sommes encore même
si je nous sommes en phase de
déconfinement pour mener à bien les
évaluations parce que je pense que c'est
une évaluation après moi je fais
confiance à l'assemblée nationale et au
sénat pour mener un travail sérieux qui
soit un travail d' enquête et pas à
charge parce que la question n'est pas
là chargé de regarder ce qui aurait pu
être mieux fait
ce qui aurait pu être mieux anticiper je
constate d'ailleurs que sur un certain
nombre de sujets ça n'est pas seulement
celle là le gouvernement actuel qui peut
être questionné mais si les
gouvernements pressent le précédent
prenons la simple question des masques
et mon or discuter centrale qui les
centrales estion centrale néanmoins il
ya eu le précédent benalla qui avaient
beaucoup créé des tensions entre
l'exécutif et le sénat puis là on sent
déjà une certaine musique bruno
retailleau justement à propos des
masques le président du groupe et l'air
au sénat qui estime que le gouvernement
je le cite à tromper les français sur le
port des masques pour cacher la pénurie
qu'est ce que vous lui répondez je ne
crois pas mais on n'est pas en
commission d'enquêté parlementaire et il
m'appartient pas n'étant pas mise de la
santé de répondre à ces questions qui
sont parfois des questions extrêmement
technique je trouve que rentrer dans la
discussion n'essayons pas de regarder
les processus qui ont été à l'oeuvre sur
les masques par exemple on ne voit bien
que la politique globale depuis 10 ans
est à une politique de réduction
je me souviens du procès qui avait été
fait roselyne bachelot d'ailleurs à
l'époque on leur la soupçonnant de tous
les maux y compris de conflit d'intérêts
sur la question des masses soit sur la
question des vaccins compris des
émissions télévisées lourdement insisté
sur le fait qu'il y avait des choses pas
normales qui s'était passé à 7 moment là
et donc on a baissé collectivement
lagarde bons voeux très bien prenons
acte de cette situation là la commission
denquête il faudra aussi qu'elle montre
ça comment un état un pays comme le
nôtre peut se mettre en situation de
pouvoir répondre à une crise sanitaire
reconnaissons lui qui était très
inattendu une dernière question sur
cette commission denquête est ce que
vous confirmez
les propos rapportés par le canard
enchaîné qui dit que le 7 mai en conseil
des ministres le président de la
république a dit le sénat c'est des
zones
le temps est encore à l'action ce n'est
pas le moment de jouer les procureurs je
ne confirme jamais les propos du conseil
des ministres c'est une règle de base
second alors affirmé que le sénat que le
sénat ne doivent pas se transformer en
procureur ça vous moi je suis désolé de
vous dire je sais pas seulement parce
que je suis ministre des relations avec
le parlement je connais bien le sénat je
pense que le scénario à coeur je suis
certain que cela aura à coeur de faire
un travail méticuleux précis d'analystes
enquête sur non pas seulement ce qui
s'est passé dans la crise mais qu'est-ce
qui quels sont les processus qui ont
fonctionné qui ont pas fonctionné qui
sont liés à une politique hospitalière
depuis dix quinze ou vingt ans alors
chacun doit pouvoir assumer tout ça
c'est aussi beaucoup calendrier
parlementaire qui c'est vrai il ya
peut-être des choses qui vont passer à
la trappe et oui effectivement le
calendrier parlementaire il a été
totalement bousculés notamment deux
réformes sont restées en suspens celle
des retraites bien sûr mais aussi
l'audiovisuel public est ce que pour
vous elles doivent être abandonnées non
mais on est en train de faire un travail
dans mon ministère et avec l'ensemble
des membres du gouvernement pour
regarder les textes que nous avons
devant nous et ceux qui peuvent être
comment dirais-je délibéré dans le temps
imparti
d'ici l'été et puis ceux qui sont
délibérées 10 alors dans ces deux cas
d'espèce les retraites mais vous auriez
pu ajouter la loi bioéthique
oui oui mais prenons les retraites mais
voyez bien que sur les retraites ce
n'est on n'est plus dans cette
temporalité là pour l'instant
est ce qu'elles reconnaissent qu est-ce
qu il ya une question un jour sur les
retraites il y aura une question enfin
la réforme des retraites il y en a eu
dans tous les cas kenai à une question
mais je dirai ce combat pour le prochain
quinquennat
on verra bien on se rappelle que c'était
absolument l'urgence à vous mais ne nous
aura pas vous aura pas échappé qui s'est
passé quelque chose dans l'intervalle
oui mais à l'époque et que nous ne
sommes pas hermétiques au monde dans
lequel on vit et à la situation de crise
dans laquelle on est il va falloir un
plan de relance n'est pas un terme à
enterrer la pleurent effort de rédaction
des pattes de d'enterrer une panthère et
c'est la question de la temporalité mais
indépendante et d'orly tic mais elle est
là elle à elle a été votée à l'assemblée
nationale elle devait
et on débat au sénat que ça veut dire
quoi enterrer un texte le texte il est
présent donc elle reviendra mais on sait
peu mais on verra ensuite de quelle
manière compte tenu de la crise que nous
à nous avons vécu compte tenu de l'
envie de le gouvernement a de travailler
sur des sujets qu'ils soient des sujets
plutôt de rassemblement reconnaissant
que sur ce texte sur les retraites il y
avait pu avoir du débat solide il ya
besoin de plutôt regarder ce qui peut
nous rassembler et aimait dire qu'il
n'ya pas une question sur les retraites
c'est pas dire la vérité à l'été va être
chargée en tout cas oui est ce que
justement les parlementaires vont siéger
cet été et jusqu'à quand alors ça
procède d'une décision là aussi du
président de la république c'est une
session extraordinaire le président
ferrand a indiqué que les travaux qui
étaient prévus et été reportée sine die
à ce stade quoiqu'il y à quelques
travaux à faire quand même de mise en
sécurité parce que tous ces travaux les
travaux de l'assemblée du béton a le
mieux les murs on parle pas des travaux
parlementaires
oui c'est du matériel n'est pas là vous
avez rêvé alors donc du coup députés et
sénateurs pour travailler tous les tout
l'été il ya sans doute une session
extraordinaire qui se déroulera mais on
verra là aussi je suis en train de
regarder de compiler l'ensemble des
textes on a le ministre d'arman a
annoncé un troisième projet de loi de
finances rectificative est ce que on
aura quelque chose autour de la relance
dans l'été est-ce qu'il ya le texte
électoral où les textes électoraux qu'il
faut produire tout ça peut nous occuper
une partie 2 est à dire quoi juillet
août
non sans que le moment n'est pas
illégitime est anormal qu'il ya une
interruption des travaux parlementaires
on redoute frais la tradition c'est
plutôt le mois d'août voilà juillet ça
va ça va il me semble mais je répète je
ne veux pas présenter ce débat tant que
pardonnez moi on risque de satisfaire je
reconnais et vous comprenez bien que
j'ai besoin de pouvoir regarder
l'ensemble des textes regardez la
temporalité dont ils ont besoin pour
être examinés dans des conditions qui
soient satisfaisantes
quelles sont les urgences que nous
aurons devant nous voyez bien que
d'autres urgences naissent au fur et à
mesure du développement de cette crise
merci tab
en tout cas il y en a qui vous écoutait
de très attentivement des deux
parlementaires là qui vont nous
rejoindre en duplex de reddition public
[Musique]
bonsoir philippe gosselin vous êtes
député et l'air de la manche et vous
êtes avec nous en duplex et bonsoir
vincent eblé vous êtes sénateur ps de
seine et marne et vous aussi vous êtes
en duplex avec nous et vous avez en face
de vous le ministre des relations avec
le parlement c'est votre ministre alors
là si un interlocuteur c'est bien lui
on va commencer par vous philippe
gosselin parce qu'on parlait du du rôle
du parlement et vous vous dites bon ça
va ça va un peu vite tout ça et puis en
même temps on n'a peut-être pas notre
mot à dire sur tout ça va ça va un peu
vite et en même temps on a beaucoup de
mal à s'y retrouver
le parlement a été mis sur la touche les
premières semaines de la gestion du duc
au vide
aujourd'hui il peut se réunir c'est vrai
mais dans une version dégradée 75
parlementaires à qui vont passer à 150
très bien mais on n'a aucune visibilité
sur les travaux parlementaires vous
l'avez évoqué il ya quelques quelques
instants et on voit bien que nous sommes
à la main du gouvernement
on ne sait pas si on va avoir un débat
ou pas et peut-être pas suivi d'un vote
d'ailleurs sur le calendrier électoral
on ne sait pas si telle ou telle réforme
reviendra ou ne reviendra pas on ne sait
pas si on siège en juillet-août si on se
la jouait tout en fait on n'a aucune
visibilité
c'est à la petite semaine et je trouve
que s'est fâché d'avoir un parlement à
ce point à la main du gouvernement dans
une démocratie donc monsieur le ministre
je vais pousser un peu dans vos
retranchements est ce que vous pourriez
quand même éclairé les les enjeux de ces
prochaines semaines je n'ose même pas
parler du mois de juillet mais au moins
un peu de visibilité sur les petites
semaines à venir
vous n'allez pas poussé dans mes
retranchements
je vais essayer d'y répondre d'abord
petit point de désaccord quand même le
parlement n'a pas été mis sur la touche
les premières semaines puisque je vous
rappelle que le parlement a voté
l'état d'urgence sanitaire dans des
conditions rapides mais on voit bien
qu'on était poussé par l'urgence du
temps c'est quand même bien la moindre
des choses non mais on n'aurait pas dit
je ne vous disait pas que c'était une
grasse mais il me semble d'ailleurs nous
étions ensemble à débattre à un après
midi entier le semble-t-il assez bon
souvenir de ce moment là nous avons
débattu et donc le parlement n'a pas été
mis sur la touche 2 0 il voudrait savoir
jusqu'à quand ils travaillent au tir il
va travailler
qu'est ce que j'ai aujourd'hui
d'identifier je reconnais que nous
sommes dans une situation d'urgence qui
nécessite parfois des adaptations qui
sont inconfortables pour vous mais qui
sont aussi inconfortable pour le
gouvernement et encore plus pour le
ministre des relations avec le parlement
on a la question des municipal si nous
avons nécessité de reporter les
municipales on verra ce que dit le
comité scientifique on verra comment se
noue le débat vous voyez bien qu'il faut
qu'on passe deux textes un premier texte
pour le report des municipales à une
date qu'il faudra déterminer et
deuxièmement un deuxième texte était un
projet de loi organique qui nécessitera
et j'imagine qu'ils ont un certain
nombre de débats débats qui seront
nourris le report des élections
sénatoriales en l'occurrence un projet
loi organique
deuxièmement on a un projet de loi de
finances rectificative un troisième
projet de loi de finances rectificative
qui vient par nécessité d'ailleurs un
certain nombre de mesures ont même été
salué sur les bancs dans lesquelles vous
siégez un certain nombre de mesures qui
sont portées ici sur le tourisme la sur
l'ajustement des mesures de chômage
partiel
ça fait un troisième sujet après nous
avons le projet de loi de règlement
c'est ça n'intéresse pas grand monde
reconnaissons le mais c'est une un
dispositif budgétaire qu'il faut voter
tout ça si vous êtes simplement sur ces
seuls textes là vous êtes déjà sur
quelque chose qui nous amène début
juillet monsieur coussin avec des
semaines puisqu'il a été assez peu et en
plus pour le tout-venant je vais dire
oui enfin le plf et je suis le gars me
diras pas été prévenus alors ce qui
était prévu et et les élections
municipales et sénateurs oui ce qui
était prévu en mai légère bien que euros
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui monsieur le ministre on est
on est capable de faire éventuellement
un petit listing au lissage de ceux qui
pourraient venir mais on n'a aucune
visibilité sur le calendrier
parlementaire et vous même à à l'instant
venez de dire qu'on n'était pas sûr
d'avoir ce débat
sur les municipales de même on devait
avoir un débat sur le tracking sur
l'application stop qu'ovide et on ne
sait plus si on a si on n'a pas un
voyez bien que le parlement est en fait
en attente du bon vouloir d'une certaine
façon
alors un petit nous alors monsieur
gosselin il me semble mais c'est
compliqué pour nous aussi amoureux mais
je dis pas le contraire mais monsieur
ghosting semblait vous avoir répondu en
donnant une temporalité jusqu'à début
juillet par ailleurs permettez moi de
vous faire un petit clin d'oeil sur le
le débat en particulier sur les
municipales j'entends des gens dans vos
rangs qui n'en veulent pas encore
faudra-t-il se mettre d'accord alors
vous allez voir marc fesneau puisque
vous aviez la chance mais non non non
effectivement nous semble plutôt ici
superfétatoire dans la mesure où c'est
au gouvernement de trancher
vous avez les armes en main vous aurez
le rapport scientifique peut-être quand
laura d'ici là puisque vous vous êtes
engagé avait publié mais il me paraît
assez logique que le gouvernement prenne
les choses les décisions bien que la loi
vigo sa mission on va laisser à ses
responsabilités juge accord alors y
allait y aller à l'assemblée nationale
qui vient de parler par l'intermédiaire
de figure au sommet du sénat ba c'est
pas mieux
vincent eblé vous êtes un peu ne
présentait pas à l'avant je vais à dire
le président de l'unfp et parce que je
sais je lui gelé urbain elle s'en est
prise
vincent eblé vous m'entendez à ces blocs
et non l'impression il ya un problème de
blocage de la liaison alors film que
cela je reviens avec vous parce que même
chose vous dites bon sur la gestion des
masques on en parle beaucoup les
collectivités locales ont beaucoup
travaillé là-dessus et il ya des
critiques qui sont mal passées oui moi
je constate qu'on a eu une gestion quand
même assez assez chaotique des masques
c'est le sujet qui restera avec les
tests je pense dans quelques semaines
dans quelques mois
il ya un côté sparadrap du capitaine
haddock très bien mais ce que je trouve
quand même un peu fort de café c'est que
beaucoup de collectivités je pense à des
régions
je pense à des agglomérations des
intercours des communes se sont investis
pour donner
des masques à leurs concitoyens et en
proximité et heureusement que ces
collectivités se sont décarcassés et
depuis quelques jours on en a eu la
semaine dernière en normandie ailleurs
des parlementaires de la majorité qui
montent au créneau mende en pointant du
doigt ces collectivités qui ont
distribué des masques comme si l'état ne
l'avait pas fait que cet art etc
je trouve que cette polémique est
déplacée et au contraire je me dis
qu'heureusement et un certain nombre de
collectivités ont pris les devants pour
assurer la protection de leurs
concitoyens est ce que vous désapprouvez
monsieur le ministre cette attitude ou
est-ce que indirectement vous l'a validé
vous vous posez une question qui est
assez simple pour moi je pense que
polémiquer sur une question qui a été
une question très sensible pour les
français n'est pas une bonne n'est pas
une bonne politique si on peut tous que
ça vienne tant que ça vu que ça vienne
j'ai vu des polémiques inverse parfois
aussi monsieur gosselin reconnaissons le
mais moi je considère que chacun a
essayé de vrai et vous l'avez très bien
dit dans les communes dans les
intercommunalités dans les départements
les régions et au fond toutes les bonnes
volontés sont bonnes à prendre et il ya
eu aussi beaucoup de bonne volonté de la
part de l'état on voit bien qu'on a eu
un sujet sur les masques il appartiendra
d'ailleurs on en a parlé tout à l'heure
à la commission denquête de regarder ce
qui nous a amenés dans cette situation
de difficulté mais je trouve que il n'y
a pas lieu de polémiquer sur un sujet
qui est extrêmement sensible pour les
français et après tout si tout le monde
se saisit de la question et chacun
essaie de faire au mieux
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle alors il
ya parfois des arriérés de presse de
vous l'entendre les mots n'est sans
doute pas étonné monsieur gosselin que
je dis ça comme ça parce que non mais
non parce que je considère qu'on peut
avoir parfois des polémiques on peut
même parfois avoir des débats et c'est
très sain en démocratie mais je ne
considère pas que sur ce sujet l'allier
lieu d'avoir des polémiques il faut
qu'on essaie de trouver les voies et
moyens peu de rassurer les français de
les protéger et le masque est une partie
de la réponse même vidéo évidemment si
ça n'est pas la seule alors nous avons
retrouvé la connexion avec vincent eblé
sénateur ps de seine et marne je disais
monsieur eblé vous écoutiez tout à
l'heure philippe gosselin qui disait bon
sur le parlement est mis sur la touche
ça va pas du tout mais vous vous êtes un
peu sur la même longueur d'onde mais
côté sénat en disant ça marche trop vite
les ordonnances et cetera oui tout à
fait il ya quelques jours
nous avons observé que le délégué
général de la république en marche a
qualifié d'irresponsable
les élus d'opposition qui ont voté
contre le plan de déconfinement du
gouvernement ça n'était pas au détour
d'une conversation c'était par
communiqué de presse donc un moment où
on fait attention on soupèse chacun des
mots utilisés d'abord c'est faire peu de
cas de ce qu'on venait de rappeler vous
même c'est à dire le vote de deux lois
d'urgence et de deux lois de finances
rectificative qui ont trouvé une issue
commune entre l'assemblée majorité
gouvernementale et le sénat qui regroupe
diverses oppositions comme chacun sait
en commission mixte paritaire nous avons
trouvé une voie sur ces textes
importants
alors si voté contre à l'occasion d'un
vote indicatif sur le plan de
déconfinement c'est irresponsable
ça veut dire qu' il faudrait toujours
voté les propositions du gouvernement
c'est juste le contraire d'un
fonctionnement démocratique que vous
semblez appelez de vos voeux et dans vos
fonctions vous y veiller je le sais donc
il ya une petite question là je dirai ce
que vous validez ce qualificatif d'
irresponsable et puis par ailleurs il ya
le recours aux osrd à la vallée-de-l'or
on va aller dans l'ordre est-ce que vous
validez cette spéciale d' irresponsable
que la soirée est faite pour que je
commente les déclarations des uns des
autres
vous avez vu qu'il vous interpelle les
parlementaires se sont vous êtes leur
ministre je leur parle je leur parle
même en dehors des plateaux télévisés
moi je crois qu'il faut toujours faire
attention aux mots moi je trouve que
c'est bien et je prends par un autre
biais que chacun puisse prendre ses
responsables c'est à vrai dire pour tout
vous dire moi je vais vous dire je
regrette que le sénat n'est pas voté
pour le plan de déconfinement mais ça
c'est une autre chose c'est le débat
politique
il me semblait que l'on peut quand même
se le dire mais il responsable c'est
malvenu mais vous avez pris en votant
vous avez pris une forme de vous avez
fait près une décision qui était celle
de ne pas nous associer
au plan de déconfinement ça n'as rien tu
es responsable
j'allais mais la question c'est vrai je
ne vais pas commenter les propos des uns
et des autres parce que je vous n'auriez
pas disait-il aux messages à taper les
mots qui vous manque vous m'entendez pas
l'exécuter si j'avais quelque chose à
dire à monsieur je vous assure que
j'avais envie de lui dire qu'il était
irresponsable je lui dirai donc que ce
n'est pas là n'est pas le cas mais moi
je regrette le vote du sénat
pour le coup je regrette le vote du
sénat parce que je pense que
collectivement nous pouvions regarder et
donner un signal qui était le signal que
après tout nous essayons de franchira
une étape difficile qui était l'étape du
déconfinement mais je prends acte du
vote du sénat
le sénat a délibéré il a voté c'est son
droit il n'a pas voté le confinement
j'en prends acte vincent eblé vous
vouliez aussi parlé des ordonnances
parce que les ordonnances c'est ce qui
permet justement de faire passer les
textes plus rapidement et là dessus
aussi vous avez des critiques à émettre
alors je crains que ce ne soit un peu
technique c'est de la technique
parlementaire mais les ordonnances et
c'est une méthode beaucoup de français
maintenant ont compris comment ça
fonctionne c'est une méthode qui
consiste à donner en quelque sorte un
pouvoir au gouvernement de se substituer
dans la définition des modalités
juridiques de réforme de lui donner en
quelque sorte la main et ça qu'on tourne
le travail du parlement alors si ça
permet d'aller vite
pourquoi pas parce qu'on n'a été prise
qui a nécessité une forme d'urgence
mais quand on observe j'irai dans le
détail l'adoption des ordonnances
on voit que ça ne permet pas toujours
d'aller beaucoup plus vite et que
ensuite il ya un problème de validation
politique de validation démocratique
avec un retour devant le parlement on a
des ordonnances ont sienne qui n'ont pas
fait l'objet de loi d'habilitation et
donc nous souhaitons j'irai limiter ce
recours on a l'argent pour que nos
concitoyens entendre à une centaine
j'irai de dispositifs d'ordonnancé
depuis le début de la crise et l'a3
confondues donc voilà j'ai demandé au
ministre de lui hérité leur concert
parlement le rôle qui est le sien de
légiférer peut-être des éléments d'euros
pour deux ou trois éléments de réponse
le premier c'est que les ordonnances
sont prévus au titre de l'article 38 de
la constitution mais ça je crois que
monsieur le blé le partage de l ont été
prévus
souvent pour des motifs où on y un
recours pour deux motifs soit parce que
le les portes et législatives sont
tellement complexes qu'on estime que
c'est plus simple de le faire par cette
voie là soit parce qu'il ya les
questions que vient de lever le
président et blake et la question de la
rapidité d'exécution
reconnaissons que dans le moment que
nous vivons depuis la crise du coup on a
virus il ya eu un recours massif aux
ordonnances pourquoi parce que en
première intention
il y avait besoin de légiférer dans un
temps très rapides qu'est ce que c'est
qu'une ordonnancé vous donner la
capacité aux gouvernements ils le disent
si on lui donne un cadre dans lequel il
peut légiférer sans passer par le
parlement
vincent eblé l'a dit oui le président
aimé parce que je sais qu'il est
vigilant ces questions là se souviendra
que au moment de l'acte de la halle de
la première loi du 23 mars j'avais pris
l'engagement le premier ministre aussi
de faire en sorte que même dans le
processus d ordonnance on associe autant
que faire se peut le parlement y compris
à la rédaction des ordonnances ce qui a
été fait dans un certain nombre de cas
ça a été transmis aux présidents des
deux assemblées hills a permis
d'ailleurs je le dis un travail parfois
utile d'ajustement des dispositifs dans
un dialogue qui était avec les
oppositions comme avec la majorité pour
dire tel dispositif annoncent il faut le
calibre est différemment parce qu'on
sent que sur le terrain il ya des choses
qui fonctionnent pas on rentre dans une
nouvelle phase et c'est là que veut en
venir sans doute le président est blessé
qu'on on a d'autres textes qui viennent
avec un certain nombre de processus qui
vise à légiférer par ordonnances et un
texte que j'aurai l'honneur de défendre
au sénat dans une huitaine de jours je
jure sur un différentes dispositions
relatif aux eaux coronavirus sur des tas
de sujet sur lequel il faut qu'on
légifère assez rapidement l'engagement
qu'a pris le gouvernement sur ce texte
nous étions à trente trois ordonnances
nous n'en sommes plus qu'à 18 c'est
d'inscrire endurci je peux dire c'est à
dire d'inscrire la loi telle que le
gouvernement l'a pensé pour que le
parlement puisse se saisir pleinement de
ses prérogatives
je vois l'écueil monsieur le président
et blaye il faut qu'on essaie de le
balancer entre les nécessités d'urgence
et en même temps la nécessité que le
parlement puisse légiférer sauver
répondu à vincent eblé en disant il faut
effectivement peut-être revoir un peu le
volume des ordonnances et vous y êtes
engagés c'est ce que vous avez dit on va
retrouver philippe caussin parce que
vous vous posez la question de il ya eu
un acte 2 un acteur un pardon un acte ii
du quinquennat et est maintenant l'après
coronavirus pas écouté l'acte 1
effectivement s'est trouvée un peu court
circuiter avec la sphère bénard
l'acte 2 qui faisait suite au gilet
jaune à des périodes assez compliqué les
mois précédents ce sans trouver aussi
court circuité par le cos vide et
d'autres événements quid des 18 mois qui
viennent alors un acte iii macron un
nouveau gouvernement
quelle quelle ambition monsieur le
ministre pour les mois et les semaines
le plus court à venir et qu'il y aura un
acte iii déjà du quinquennat assure
l'appellera e3 mais voyez bien que la
situation créée par le coronavirus j'en
parlais tout à l'heure va nécessiter sur
le champ économique sur le champ social
sur le champ démocratique probablement
de réfléchir un certain nombre
d'orientations qui soit soit la
prolongation d'un certain nombre de
choses qui avaient été portées par cette
majorité depuis 2017 soit parfois des
orientations nouvelles qu'il faudra
porter on verra si il faut le dénommé
acte iii est en tout cas vous voyez bien
qu'on est face à un défi de la dette
un défi économique un défi de relance un
défi touristique enfin monsieur gosselin
que connaissent ces sujets largement
aussi bien que moi qu'il va nécessiter
la mobilisation de tous au fond l'acte
iii il va être aussi un défi pour si je
peux me permettre pour les oppositions
parce que dans l'actuelle dans l'acte ii
on a été les uns et les autres
quand je dis les uns les autres je dis
bien les uns et les autres peut-être
trop les uns face les uns contre les
autres les uns contre les autres ou en
chiens de faïence et il me semble que
dans le défi quelqu'un qui est celui de
notre pays et le défi qui nous est porté
dans cette crise qui est majeure il ya à
la fois ce que 2 sera la responsabilité
du gouvernement est de cette majorité
mais il ya aussi une responsabilité on
parlait des responsabilités halte à
l'heure de comment on pourra sans se
compromettre
il ya une opposition il ya une majorité
qu'elles sont dans l'acte iii les
chemins qu'on pourra faire ensemble sur
les sujets économiques sur les sujets de
relance il me semble qu'il ya des sujets
sur lequel nous pourrions dans un acte
iii si c'est comme ça qu'ils s'appellent
à voir les uns vis-à-vis des autres et
satar exempt par exemple quel sujet bas
sur le sujet de la relance ou d'un plan
de relance touristique sur le sujet d'un
plan de relance sur les questions
aéronautiques et automobiles avec l'envi
quand même de procéder à une transition
écologique peut-être que nous sur le
sujet de l'équation budgétaire parce que
l'équation budgétaire c'est des dépenses
puis c'est des recettes
peut-être que nous pourrions en
responsabilité on parle avec monsieur
les blés de la question de la
responsabilité essayé de trop
oui des voix commune mais ça ne procède
pas seulement de l'opposition ça procède
aussi de l'attitude de la majorité
mais je dis que c'est nous réussirions
aussi non pas seulement un acte iii de
ce gouvernement mais le moment qui va
jusqu'en 2022
si les uns et les autres nous regardions
ce qu'elle a à l'heure de la france
puisque vous interpellez fils gaussin
ils vous répondent rapidement été
approuvée retrouver vincent eblé
oui moi je crois qu'il faut fixer une
ligne de conduite en réalité il reste 18
mois très utile avant l'élection
présidentielle fait la main tendu la
main tendu la main tendue du droit on
vous l'apprenait que fait-on quand on
envoie une majorité qui du reste est un
peu en train de s'éclater où il ya des
divergences d'approchés quelle ligne va
être choisie est effectivement déjà
concrètement comment vous comptez en ok
on va pas répondre à cette question ce
soir fibres de ça parce qu'il vous a
répondu tendu la main marc fesneau pia
vincent eblé qu'il vous a posé sa
question mais vous qu on comprend bien
que voilà que c'est la question qui est
dans l'air vincent eblé
justement parlez de relance économique
de finances votre question le vous
voulez qu'on en vienne aux finances ce
que j'avais vraiment une question sinon
rapidement parce que là c'est le temps
le temps des vagues très vite alors sur
les financiers de taxes bien ou des
meneurs les finances s'il vous plaît
parce que ça va être traitée leur
ressenti allons-y sur les finances ce
matin j'écoutais monsieur le ministre le
maire sur france info qui évoquait la
nécessité de payer cette crise est il
indiqué qu'il n'était pas favorable à
recourir à l'impôt on voit bien
évidemment comment on flatte le
contribuable en lui disant en aucun cas
je n'aurais eu recours à l'impôt mais
enfin on sait bien
si on ne paye pas par l'impôt maintenant
on va payer par la dette
et si on paye par l'adec c'est juste de
l'impôt reportez votre question est
suprieur n'auront pas à payer tout de
suite ce sont nos enfants ou nous mêmes
un peu plus tard si on est encore jeunes
qui devront bien le payer à un moment ou
à un autre et jeu blanc vous dire que
on a aussi la possibilité on voit le
chemin de faire travailler les français
un peu plus donc on va être question
acteurs beaucoup plaident ce sentier par
exemple le medef etc
on peut revenir sur l'assurance chômage
dont l'apparence de votre site et de la
réforme et vous n'avez pas pris
l'engagement de renoncer à cette réforme
alors que vous avez pris l'engagement de
renoncer à beaucoup d'autres mais celle
là non donc dans la situation économique
qui s'annonce avec beaucoup de chômeurs
un réformé le système course et
l'assurance chômage c'est quand même une
bombe
donc est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
pourquoi vous bloquez sur par exemple la
question de l'usf
je pense qu'il ya des français qui
pourraient payer qui ont les moyens à
leur payer la réponse de marc fesneau de
cette crise parce qu'évidemment voulez
bien
allez y mais tout le monde peut y
contribuer il compare craignons ces
marques feront pleurer à piran isf selon
des modalités que je vous laisse
répondre mais qui permettrait d'éviter
oui le sérail et chats je vous laisse
répondre marc fesneau
les blés je sais que tout le monde rêve
du monde d'après mais au fond vous dit
pardonnez moi vous dit exactement avant
le corps et d'un virus la même chose
après de corona virus c'est-à-dire le
rétablissement d isf
vous êtes beaucoup plus experts que moi
dans ces questions dont je ne vais pas
m'aventurer méliès elle 7,4 milliards
d'euros autant je me souvienne c'est
toujours ça de pris
dans ce cas de panne ça n'est pas à la
mesure de ce que va être la dette et
l'endettement du pays
ce qu'elle est pour vous le dites vous
vous me dites vous vous arc bouté sur l'
isf et je pourrais vous dire monsieur
les blés vous vous arquebouté sur l' isf
et donc je peux chacun sa route
la question qui va nous est posée mais
on va conclure l'aps tout ça est ce qu a
dit bruno le maire sait quand même que
c'est par la croissance et par la
dynamique créée par la croissance que
nous retrouverons huriaux plutôt que par
l'impôt qu'il faut qu'on essaie de
trouver un équilibre c'est bien le débat
que nous aurons sans doute dans le plfr
3 et à la rentrée au moment du bilan en
tout cas vous là vous l'avez bien bien
introduit vincent eblé merci beaucoup
vincent eblé et philippe caussin d'avoir
été en duplex avec nous pour audition
publique il est largement temps marc
andreu trouver le regard dit
thréard du figaro bonsoir yves bonsoir
bon sous le ministre bonsoir j'ai écouté
le président et blé et il m'a inspiré
une idée à bien vous avez raison mais
plutôt des finances au sénat csf
vous l'avez pas complètement supprimée
il y est c'est fait et pourquoi vous ne
supprime huriez pas les sf sur
l'immobilier pour relancer le marché de
l'immobilier est en train de s'effondrer
voit que la boîte à idées sorties oui et
bien contre ce que vous proposez vous
est président et blaye ya une petite
différence et en suisse il faut choisir
vous le président et blé est sans doute
monsieur gosselin s'il avait parlé de ce
sujet une nouvelle petite différence
faut qu'on essaie de trouver un chemin
les uns et les autres ce sera une piste
pour relancer les mobiles je le l'idée
c'est quand même plutôt de stabiliser le
taux de prélèvement voyez bien qu'on est
plutôt dans un registre de dépenses qui
sont très accrue et c'est normal dans la
période de crise que nous avons vécue je
signale que le président de la
république et la chancelière merkel ont
annoncé un certain nombre de mesures qui
vous fait 100 milliards d'euros oui qui
vont quand même très loin et qui
permettront aussi de répondre au défi
celui de l'art justement c'est ça gérer
un doute sur cette enveloppe de 500
milliards d'euros
madame merkel avait l'air plein de
bonnes de bons sentiments
est ce que ces fonds les états vont
devoir les rembourser
quand ils seront une fois qu'ils seront
exploitées on va regarder le mécanisme
ne peux pas vous répondre sur cette
question là mais en tout cas la volonté
qui a été manifestée par le président de
la république et la chancelière merkel
ces deux d'identifier et donc en commun
de gérer une dette en tout cas une
partie de cette dette qui sera créée par
ces fonds est de mobiliser des moyens à
hauteur de 500 milliards qui viennent
s'ajouter d'ailleurs aux sommes qui
avaient déjà été prévues
mais la nouveauté on verra comment ça va
se traduire comme proposition la
commission européenne là c'est une
parole du compte ce qu'on appelle le
couple franco-allemand en tout cas c'est
comme ça qu'on l'appelle en france c'est
une volonté de partager aussi l'effort
de la dette et donc évidemment il faudra
bien sans doute le rembourser mais la
question
et je trouve que ce qui est posé et qui
est intéressant c'est à la fois le fait
de ne pas renoncer sur les questions
centrales que sont les indépendants
stratégique la transition écologique et
en même temps de mettre puissamment des
moyens européens et de façon mutuel il
faut que l'europe se redresse face à
l'âge et aux états unis et louis et je
trouve que le message qui est envoyé par
la chancellière et par le président est
un assez joli message ou moment beaucoup
de gens doutent de l'europe et j'espère
que sa stratégie du couple
franco-allemand part du flamboyant et
alors ils étaient côte à côte
l'allemagne la france ou les où je veux
en venir deux systèmes de santé et qui
coûte le même prix
oui il y en a un qui a très bien marché
oui les bois l'autre oui le français a
pas bien marché
oui pourquoi on a des questionnements
alors certains disent et une affaire de
décentralisation pas des centrales je
suis pas sûr que ce soit comme ça qu'il
fallait poser le problème le système
italien est extrêmement décentralisée
j'ai cru voir qu'ils avaient des
difficultés mais sans qu'il faudra faire
un bilan un peu avec rebours de ce qui
va se passer y compris en allemagne
alors l'allemagne vous savez que ce sont
des instituts hospitalier privatiser un
peu comme l'école publique l'école sous
contrat son contrat en france oui je
connais mal j'ai perçu ça avec de
l'argent qui est public sur quoi ça peut
nous interroger nous français c'est est
ce que le système était assez agile au
fond quelle est la capacité de
comprendre un mot un peu savant la
capacité de résilience d'un système à
partir d'une dépense publique comme en
face à un virus comme celui là on peut
réagir rapidement comment on peut passer
de singly la bureaucratie
en tout cas on entend le ministre véran
le dit c'est à dire comment on peut
réorganiser j'entends chez les
personnels soignants à la fois la
question de la revalorisation personnel
salariales mais aussi la question d'un
système qui s'est trop bureaucratique
changer de travail et des erreurs
politiques mais aussi disons aussi des
choses dans le pic épidémique que nous
avons connu le système hospitalier a
tenu quand même rendez vous rue marge de
celle de même que par rapport à
l'allemagne on qu'on a pété mais on peut
on peut se poser des questions en
première intention on a le sentiment que
le système allemand a été moins
intentions d'accor donc mais le système
français à résister alors donc la
changer le monde et ses déboires
personnels soignants et la capacité de
mobilisation et d'agilité du die welt
qu'un que vous connaissez bien qui
s'appelle françois bayrou s'est exprimé
hier il
il faut un nouveau modèle d'organisation
de la société alors ses vallons c'est
que on savait roux a souvent des très
belles formules littéraires général mais
ça veut dire quoi c'est à dire que vous
dites ça passe pas nécessairement par de
la décentralisation supplémentaires moi
je pense être un nouveau modèle est ce
que c'est plus lourd aux bahamas est ce
que c'est il ya deux sujets c'est
d'abord quand les ans les collectivités
ont des compétences et ce qu'elles
peuvent les exercer pleinement est-ce
qu'il ya pas un enchevêtrement de
compétence entre elles et avec l'état
qui fait qu'au fond personne ne décide
mais liberté et compétent ça va avec
responsabilité c'est à dire que quand
une crise bien ou quand un sujet vient
ça veut dire que les collectivités sans
nom part seule au fond d'ailleurs les
lander allemands quand ils ont un
problème ils le gèrent eux-mêmes sans se
retourner vers leur état fédéral donc
c'est un changement dû parfois ils
s'opposent à l'état fédéral parfois ils
s'y opposent un changement de culture
donc c'est un sujet 2 est ce que dans la
décentralisation les pouvoirs sont bien
assumée par ceux qui devraient les
assumer et donc d'essence et la réponse
est non la gauche dénonce on voit bien
qu'il ya des enchevêtrements qui reste
d'accord et c'était la question
d'ailleurs de la loi 3d qui est porté
par jacqueline gourault et que le
président de la république et le
gouvernement portent parce qu'il ya une
question il ya une deuxième question là
dedans que porte aussi françois bayrou
c'est la question de la différenciation
c est ce que les réponses elles sont les
mêmes d'un territoire à l'autre et les a
peut-être je pense que non il faut
regarder alors donc faut changer la
constitution pour ça pour faire en sorte
oui il faut quand même qu'on une région
alors adam le faire faut changer la
constitution oui notre pays est assez
paradoxal c'est qu'il est très attaché
au principe d'égalité et qu'en même
temps ils réclament beaucoup de
différenciation et donc il faut
conjuguer cet esprit d'égalité en disant
il faut pas que ce soit différent d'une
région à une autre
et en même temps les mêmes qui disent il
faut qu'on le vit actuellement entre les
rouges et les verts
oui mais c'est un mais je le disais tout
à l'heure en introduction c'est que l'on
sait c'est là je sais pas si c'est koh
lanta parce que ce serait sûrement
d'entrée ça serait un jeu ce qui n'est
pas en prison que les entier mais c'est
la première fois qu'on met à l'oeuvre ce
qu'avait dit le président de la
république je vous la deux ans résidant
attentif au moment du congrès des maires
de 2010 est le principe de
différenciation l'a mis en oeuvre au
moment du plan de déconfinement yves il
faut une
d'après vous il faut une fixation là
dessus constitutionnel ça peut apporter
sur une telle question posée vous avez
une formule pendant la campagne
présidentielle du président de la
république qui disait pas que girondins
il faut aller vers un pacte girondins on
a surtout vu le jacobin au début de son
quinquennat
est ce que vous êtes favorable à ce
pacte aux girondins et est ce que vous
estimez qu'à la faveur de cette crise
l'exécutif auquel vous appartenez s'est
rapproché justement des élus locaux mais
moi je vais vous dire je suis un élu
local
hier soir minutes redevenu élu local
conseiller municipal dans mac os
marchenoir dans le loir et cher
je me sens très à l'aise dans ce
gouvernement est dans cette majorité sur
la question de quoi je trouve qu'à une
grande injustice qui nous est faite sur
la question aux girondins jacobins
vraiment une grande injustice par des
gouvernements qui nous est faite au
gouvernement et à cette majorité
pardonnez moi quand dans le précédent
quinquennat sur un coin de table un
dimanche soir et vous savez très bien
quoi je fais référence on l'a décidé de
découper les régions en faisant fi de
leur histoire de leur culture
lors de leur champ économique de leur
coopération vous croyais que c'était
girondins s'étaient jacobins
pardonnez-moi politique de bon sur un
coin de table parce qu'il fallait donner
des gages d'un point de vue budgétaire
on a décidé de raboter en deux ou trois
ans 13 milliards d'euros aux
collectivités locales sans les prévenir
de rien ouais c'était jacobins où
c'était girondins mais on a fait ça
billy's élevé liste probablement comment
s'est-elle six n'ont su que c'était même
avant cet épisode là qu importe mais je
veux dire je ne vais pas me laisser
donner des leçons de jacobinisme add
prédécesseur qui n'ont passé leur temps
à ça alors peut-être qu'on n'a pas été
assez clair peut-être qu on a été
maladroit ok mais sur le fond macro
gouvernement sur cette question legs est
très ouvert il est beaucoup plus ouvert
je rappelle que dans la révision
constitutionnelle nous avions introduit
la question de la différenciation il
donc je suis assez à l'aise pour voyager
avec ce sujet dans les mois qui viennent
deux ou trois petites choses
la majorité présidentielle va prendre un
petit coup là dans la semaine puisque il
ya un nouveau groupe qui va se
constituer donc elle n'aura plus la
majorité absolue le parti présidentiel
mais pour le modem c'est royal c'est à
dire que vous vous êtes vous sorti
renforcé de cette affaire parce que vous
bougez pas et vous allez devenir un
allié absolument indispensable pour
l'amour nous met déjà un solide est
indispensable et gré des mois et des
années depuis 2007 nous avions
puis acquérir cette place dans la
majorité présidentielle et donc sa
sacrée à la fois des obligations est
plutôt des obligations de solidité
communes comme le groupe modem a pu
montrer et démontrer depuis trois ans et
pas question de se lancer quelque chose
qui ressemblerait à du marchand d'art de
paris c'est à dire le parti présidentiel
par un peu en lambeaux finalement il
s'était constitué rapidement il perd un
député je crois tous les deux mois oui
enfin il y avait 300 oui il est très
bien c'est un parti qui était nouveau
avec un certain nombre de gens qui
n'avaient pas d'expérience politique
et ça se voit je trouve passion des
amateurs non non je ne trouve pas non
simplement ils ont pas le cynisme
d'autres d'accord c'est ça ce que
voulait dire par amateurs oui ils ont
pas le cynisme d'autres alors parfois ça
a des avantages et moi je trouve ça
beaucoup davantage parfois ça peut avoir
des inconvénients mais enfin quand même
d'avoir des gens qui ne regardent pas le
monde politique uniquement avec cynisme
avec un peu de nouveauté avec 1,9 fois
je vous assure pour moi qui suit vous
rendez à l'hommage de mardi
c'est de la fraîcheur c'est bien vous
dire c'est juste une petite hier le
président de la république a rendu
hommage et a célébré le président de
gaulle il avait célébré le colonel
pendant la guerre de 40 qui a résisté
aux allemands qui avaient tenté de
résister aux allemands de gaulle c'est
la référence pour emmanuel macron c'est
la référence pour quelqu'un comme vous
alors que françois bayrou il est de
l'école de cannes met alors à dia dans
une émission télévisée qu'il n'était pas
complètement sur la ligne historique de
notre famille de pensée qui était pas
très gaullienne moi je trouve que la
figure historique
le parcours du général de gaulle et des
est exemplaire à bien des égards c'est
une référence pour vous en 40 pendant la
guerre c'est à la sortie de la guerre
d'une préférence ou que l'homme le
comportement le président de la
république est exemplaire à bien des
égards et je trouve que c'est remuer des
figures exemplaire dans l'histoire de
france
il y en a 12 6 mais celle-là est
éminente je trouve que c'est merci merci
marc fesneau cerci yves d'abord merci
marc rozé la fin de votre audition
publique non en dernier et puis merci
aussi à nos parlementaires qui ont été
frustrés j'imagine mais bon là ça va
très très vite pour tout le monde
c'est la fin d'audition publique qui
revient lundi prochain à 19h bonne
soirée
[Musique]